well earlier I spoke to Maria Zakharova
the press secretary for the Russian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs and she told
me that Russia would do everything to
protect its citizens on the ground in
Syria
she also said Russia has suspicions that
the British government may be holding
Ullaeus Creepo
against her will I started by asking her
what she thought about president Trump's
tweet threatening Russia with missile
attacks I was bit surprised that such
strong messages are sent through social
networks because this is actually the
matter and the keys to take a phone and
to call your partners all over the world
and rude do you still think that this
world this word is existing in our world
I'm I really doubt think it's gone
beyond that in terms of measuring the
United Way beyond that you know I don't
think we should mark the words saying
this word is rude and this is a polite
word because we have Syria on board I
mean with all these troubles happening
to the to the people and children and
what we actually want and I'm 100% sure
that American people British people
French people I mean common people they
really want peace for this for this
country but let's talk about the
imminence of a strike Donald Trump has
said it might not happen now it might
not happen soon but still giving the
sense that it is going to happen is that
the assessment of the Russian Federation
that the United States and its allies
will launch some form of military
operation pretty soon in Syria in 2015
President of Russia during his
statements in
in New York you had had water asked for
world cooperation on Syria on combating
terrorists for these years I mean about
three years past our proposal is still
on the table and we actually are looking
forward closer cooperation with other
countries on Syria we really wanted and
we really needed but it doesn't seem to
be happening that's the point the
missiles are coming according to the
President of the United States and
mainly clarify no please don't ask me
about what US president is doing please
say I was asking you about the
assessment of the Russian Federation and
indeed the response this is very
important the response of the Russian
Federation should missiles be launched
Russia should protect its people on the
ground of course Russia should protect
its people surround what about the
incoming missiles we had this from the
ambassador to Lebanon that they would be
shot down in the basis from which they
come attacked I would have stressed one
more time and that was the idea of our
ambassador in Lebanon as well that
Russia will protect its people on the
ground
this is Obus which is this this is the
task for each and every country in the
world to protect the citizens on the
ground
so if Russia lives are lost if Russian
blood is spilt will American blood be
spilled I really don't want to even
think about this because I you know I
just want to remind you and myself and
everybody who will watch this this
interview that we're living in 2018 we
have all sort of communication including
Twitter and we can resolve all the
questions like that just picking up the
phone just sending messages and I think
that this is the case which which should
be resolved through the communication
but not through force I was reading just
yesterday that the last leader of the
Soviet Union Mikhail Gorbachev no less
the Nobel Peace Prize winner saying that
it is imperative that these two
presidents must meet that a summit must
take
as he held with President Reagan and
President George HW Bush that this is
the way to sort it out that is his
opinion as a person in my personal
capacity I can say that the only thing I
want as a mother as a wife as a just a
citizen of my country and actually a
citizen of the world because I have lots
of friends all over the world all I want
is peace peaceful for both for Syrian
people for others and especially I
wasn't peaceful my country you said
earlier that Russia holds no candle that
doesn't necessarily support all of
President Assad's policies or indeed his
methods I'm not an advocate for Syria
and especially for mr. Assad actually
before chemical disarmament we had
before even that mr. Assad was the best
friend not of Moscow but of London and
Washington he's not our guy he's much
more your guy we are in Syria just to
stop terrorism and stop spreading ISIL
and other terrorist organization this
specific attack which is led us to the
situation we're in it's the Russian
position that it wasn't an attack that
it has been let us be absolutely clear
for that particular case that happened a
couple of days ago we we are we are
hundred percent sure that that was a
clear provocation for example white
helmets we are absolutely sure were
involved in this provocation but what
the Russian military is is there was no
chemical weapons tackle together and
that these scenes were faked
they were acted exactly together exactly
and what we need to just to prove what
that was was it just a provocation to be
shown as a chemical attack or there were
any sort of chemical materials what we
propose is to send the representatives
of organization of prohibition of
chemical weapons to the ground
who are you in vacuum the experts and
representatives or
international organization prohibition
of chemical you yes and the World Health
Organization want to come in as well
they can do together but of course the
first place is for organization for
prohibition of chemical weapon onto the
street house you must be delighted about
the recovery of Ullaeus Crete now
oh yes the only thing that we actually
want to be sure that this is for real
because for that particular moment we
have just zero information from official
London about what is going on with her
you think she's actually being abducted
as the Russian embassy said in London
abducted we we have such suspicions we
have such a feeling yes held against her
will probably yes because we you know
the the whole issue it's a mystery we do
not have any sort of official
information what has what happened in
Salisbury I know that Great Britain is
spread is is full of cameras I don't
know how they who you call them
CCTV close television cameras or
something like that which is actually a
sort of providing security in the
country so where are the materials from
these cameras why they are so secret
that nobody can present them to the
audience accusations should be made
after investigation but not before well
there are some in the British political
world who perhaps more towards your view
on questions to be asked I'm thinking of
the leader of the Opposition Jeremy
Corbyn who may in the next election
become Prime Minister is his take on
this the idea that there more questions
need to be asked and and indeed when it
comes to Syria that no action should
take place without it I'm not I don't
think that he's advocating brush I think
that he's much more about what question
he's very pragmatic and he is asking
questions which are Russia is asking and
journalists and the media are asking
because actually we want to know what
happened and why we're refused of
providing us this information so oh he
is talking about it's just a pragmatic
thing because if you are accusing a
whole state in doing such things you
should give any sort you know of playing
cards
you should put some cards on the table
what do you have we just have a poker
face maria vladimirovna we appreciate
you giving us so much time thank you
very much indeed